hi everyone so before I kind of go into
my top I'd like to say a little bit
about what I do attics or what most of
us do at Accenture technology labs so
one of our jobs is to kind of go and
research into new technology and new
algorithms any other latest stuff that's
happening on one side but on the other
side also to look for gaps in the client
space where people are looking for like
a new solution and they don't have the
solution directly from their regular
either regular data scientists or their
regular staff in general and a lot of
the times the clients we work with
typically will have a data science team
who are setting up their a be testing
who are doing other other things and
they still have like some things that
they want to do and they don't have the
bandwidth to actually do it so my slides
and my day-to-day work is kind of pulled
on two ends on the one end I am really
trying to make my business savvy clients
understand what's going on in the data
science world or how or how the solution
that we are creating is actually making
a difference in their company and on the
other hand I'm working with technology
that's like hot out of some where it's
breaking most of the time but it's also
giving me something that I want and
there's a good reason why it did this
like huge introduction and you realize
it as a talk most forward so the
specific thing I have been working in
natural language processing for the past
one year and and pretty much I've worked
in like four different projects and in
all the projects I kind of needed to do
some kind of text extraction initially I
would and also in all of the projects
like it would be with some kind of data
typically data does not come with
training data or annotated data so
that's also another like huge issue
which I face regularly I feel like a lot
of businesses probably faith that data
don't come with training data and
annotating data is expensive it requires
expert knowledge
so people always try to get around like
what can we do so that we have to do
minimum annotation or combine a human
annotation with some more some more
logic so initially when I was extracting
data and I did not have training data I
would try to do something hacky use
topic modeling to get some kind of
labeling like take take all like do
unsupervised learning take all
everything in one cluster and label it
as something and then use that as a
labeling set and it typically does not
work that well and that's one of the
reason I tried to go in the classical
direction of data extraction the other
thing is that like doing doing a range
of unsupervised things also makes you
kind of miss a lot of what you want so a
lot of the times you have an idea of
what you want like if you want if you
want CEOs who are you know who have
received Series A funding it's very hard
to do topic modeling and kind of get
label data for that thing out of you're
out of let's say CrunchBase data that
you have gathered so hence the reason
for going in a very circuitous route or
a traditional route however you want to
put it towards data extraction so a lot
of a lot of business process actually
requires reading like mortgage
applications you kind of need to look at
the backgrounds of the people applying
for the loan you need to extract
specific things specific numbers credit
scores there are different kinds of
legal contracts there are other things
in in the academic space there are
people who really need to read papers to
kind of extract specific information out
of it and typically in most of this
cases actually I was recently talking to
somebody in DNA sequencing and they were
actually saying that they had to take
the sequence and then search through
papers and find a paper that actually
talks about how that sequence if it's
altered will cure the disease and the
process of actually having to read
through all those papers to get that is
a lot of really expert work
and some of the things that I'm going to
talk about the idea is to reduce the
training or even remove it to a certain
depending on the problem that you're
doing
so the first typical approach to any
text is probably not supposed to turn is
you need to tokenize a text you can you
need to normalize the word sense
disambiguation do parsing part of speech
and if this is like regular text that's
written in papers or if it's if it's
normal English most of the time a parser
like the Stanford NLP parser that I use
will do all of this for you the amount
of data that I've seen or the variety of
data that I've seen there are types of
data that actually don't follow the
language or the grammar for instance
people will write a different language
but you still use English characters so
it's very hard to kind of use like a
parser to understand what's going on at
that time you might have to write write
your own code custom code to do that
another place where I have seen the
parser to completely fail is machine
generated data and if you get machine
generated text data and you can actually
trace the source that was that generated
that data it would be quite easy to
parse it because it's kind of robotic
and repetitive again most of the time I
actually don't get the source so that
point I have to write my own parsers or
if I want to extract things like port
numbers emails it's again hard to go
through the regular language parser but
yeah with regular text I think any
parser and ltk or Stanford LP will do it
and the typical typical approach that I
take is a first eye and this is also
very standard first I try to find by
ad-hoc means like relevant sentences so
let's say if I was scraping this data
from the web I would probably find
certain sections of the HTML that's
interesting if it were papers certain
sections might contain what I want and
extracting relevant sentences kind of
makes like the job computationally much
easier because the less text you pass
through your pipeline the better it is
the
kind of find find I call them candidates
but find the phrases that or unigram
czar by grams or trigrams that would
represent what you're trying to find in
some cases for instance the example that
I'll go through here in in case of
diseases I've seen nouns and different
combination around nouns are a good
candidate
sometimes other combinations of past the
parts which tags could also be good
candidates and the next step would be
extract features and this could be bag
of words around nouns it could also be
word avec feature vectors for the
phrases that you're looking at and once
you have that and you have some training
data that you can map and balance you
can you can feed that to a machine
learning algorithm such as logistic
regression and get what you want so for
instance if in in the problem that I'll
show I'm looking for disease name names
and I expect my classifier to tell me
yes this is a disease name no that's not
a disease it's all well and good but map
training data that's the part that's
really hard I mean where do you get the
training data and I mean how do you how
do you generate it in the specifically
in the medical space I've seen people
there are companies which even have MDS
in their annotating group who actually
tell them what the text is about and
it's very hard especially at Accenture
where I mean we try to solve like for
client at least start with so finding a
solution that satisfies like four
different clients and people also come
to us when they have a lot of data and
nobody is looking at the data so in
general it's very hard to just get
annotated training data so what what we
try to do is we try we've taken like a
different approach and we've taken the
route of going into using the domain
knowledge and trying to incorporate the
domain knowledge in the algorithm and
have minimal training data so this is a
project called snorkel and deep dive and
it's come out of Stanford out of
Professor Chris race group effort has
there because she's a really nice guy
and if you feel interested about this
you can go and talk to him and he's very
excited if people want to work with the
snorkel and the deep dive technology and
the thing that snorkel promises in their
paper actually they use 10 training data
and they use hundred annotated data and
you could call it like 110 training
points as such and they get kind of like
an 80% f1 score like a point eight f1
score now the paper is of course you
know I mean people really know their
data at that point and it's done for a
specific space so my guess is that in
reality you might need like a thousand
annotated data for a space that you
don't know a lot about but a thousand is
also a very small number for like if you
have millions of data points mmm and the
promise and the reason why I mean why
you don't need the training data it's
not magic it's basically writing rules
so you eventually you end up writing
rules things you know about your data
and I will go into it in more details
and those rules are kind of modeled with
parameters in them and then the code
basically returns the weights of the
rules and how the rules conflict and
which ones should dominate and that
produces a training training set for the
classifier so the main main takeaway
from the snorkel environment is that it
doesn't need training data and the
reason it doesn't need training data is
it needs very good rules and eventually
and in the process of getting to the
rules is actually quite non-trivial if
you're starting a new project what
happens is we interview people who are
experts in their fields especially
specifically in the client teams and we
convert their knowledge into rules and
the better your rules are the better the
code will perform and in some sense they
if the work of converting domain
knowledge into rules is less work
compared to just sitting there
annotating saying yes no yes no do like
thousands of sentences so here is the
snorkel pipeline
so you again the first few are kind of
similar you get the text that's relevant
you get the candidates and then you
write the rules the rules could be
something like you know I for instance
for the specific case of medical data
I have things like I want treatment
before before the candidate so those
that those are typical rules or I don't
want the word disease in the candidate
because it's a generic word and I'm
looking for specific diseases and the
rules kind of keep getting better as you
do it like the first time you write the
rules everything is terrible your
results are also terrible and then you
keep iterating and keep using the UI
also to look at the data which keeps
making it better
another thing that has really helped me
in one of the project is that just
communication with SME and the person in
that project just knew a lot about the
data and he could just tell me a list of
things that I could convert into rules
very soon also if someone gives you like
a thousand training data there are ways
to take that training data and convert
it into converted into a set of rules
that that can be outputted by a code so
the specific data example that I'm going
to go through is an FDA drug label the
FDA drug label is typically what comes
behind your talent all bottle the answer
that I'm looking for is what disease
does the drug treat so this is already a
drug label I don't have to worry about
the drug I just have to pick out the
disease there's a section called
indications and usage and if you just
look at zoom in to this zoom in to this
label user you will see most of the
information is there and that's when I
what I mean when I say extract sentences
that have relevant information and then
use those sentences to find which
diseases to drugs treat and these are
some typical examples for instance one
of one sentences it is indicated for
treating respiratory disorder caused due
to allergy one thing I want here is I
want respiratory disorder
I don't want allergy and for the relief
of symptoms of depression I actually
want depression here
so my color coding is not right and then
anticonvulsant like this sentence is
talking about anticonvulsant and then
there are sentences where sometimes it's
very hard to just read it and say what
they are talking about the other data
set that I'm interested in is clinical
trials data and this is very interesting
because if you want again to do a
clinical trial
apparently the typical route to go is go
into PubMed and basically search for
whatever you're trying to search and
search for the drugs for the type of
trial you're doing and basically get all
the papers and read the papers and
figure out what has happened in the past
where is this information is typically
there in all of PubMed and you have
things like the first sentence we
present a case of a ten-year-old boy who
had severe relapsing pancreatitis three
times within three weeks after starting
the treatment of methylphenidate NIDA
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
so we kind of wandered in for the age
group the gender the side effect what it
was treating how long was the duration
so this is something and this data it's
very hard to get training data for
something like this like you would need
so many SME hours to get training data
for this as it's nearly impossible but
what we want is this is the unstructured
text at the end of it we want tables
that have these information and these
are like the entity goals that we are
looking for in some cases we just want
the entities in some other cases we want
also relationship between entities for
instance the relationship between
pancreatitis and Ritalin is that it is
an adverse effect or a side effect the
relationship between ADHD and Ritalin is
that it treats Ritalin so we are also
trying to recover the different types of
relationships and at the end of the day
you would have different either files or
databases that will get stored in your
in your file system so now I'll go into
a little bit more details of the process
so the first process is candid
extraction and I spoke a little about it
I in one example I said like all nouns
are probably my candidates typically mmm
you want a candidate set that does not
that's not too big so if you take
something like all noun phrases it is
too big and it is it pretty much like
covers all your data and it's very hard
to work with that big data set so you
want something which has like 80% recall
20% precision so you want a candidate
extractor that that covers every
possible thing but not everything and so
the first line is kind of like the this
is like one example for one of our
client cases and the first line is a
deposit AG that kind of we identified
for that specific candidate extractor
and in the second line and what we have
is some more characteristics of what we
wanted and in this case you see there's
a long red X and I fell have covered it
because it's proprietary but this
basically has this tag X has like eight
expressions separated by ORS and what we
got at the end of it and we combine
these two and took an intersection of
them but what we got and they at the end
of it was too accurate so it was like 60
percent accurate which meant it was also
throwing out a lot like we were missing
a lot so you also want something that's
very general so in this specific case we
just removed everything that we had and
just put VPNs in there because VPN was a
specific thing we were looking at so
it's very important to be general but
again just going with things like noun
typically is too big to handle another
question that I always get so I decided
to kind of put this slide in is that
snorkle kind of takes the features
automatically so you don't have to worry
about features typically the last time I
gave this talk I was not using snorkel
so I spend like quite a bit of time
talking about what effect features
talking about like bag-of-words features
and things like that I don't have any of
those slides but I wanted to show like
the scent a typical sentence structure
and the features are basically things
that come out of the parser like pass
tags
context the dependency trees the
character offsets with supposition and
once you identify the fighter candidate
just the snorkel automatically goes and
picks up the free ship features so you
actually don't have to worry about that
part at all next I will go into the rule
functions so this is what like a typical
set of roof unction look like and the
the parts are typically outputs things
like lemmas or words or the dependency
tree or the past acts and you will learn
the process of learning the rules like
this these are a set of very but they're
sort of complete rules when you start
with the rules you typically have like
three positive ones three negative ones
they don't give good results but they
give you some results and you kind of
iterate through that and typical like
for instance this is these rules are
about genes so if you have the gene in
the post window then it's most likely
your answer or if you have genotype
independency parents then it's your
answer so these are things these are
rules that were specifically written by
biologists and they really knew their
domain well the typically most people
don't know their domain that well and
that comes true just looking at the data
or just even doing simple things like
bag of words on your candidates to see
how your candidates are doing and
eventually after a few iterations you
can reach a pretty good space the other
thing that's really important is to look
at how your rules are doing before doing
any learning so basically the code
returns which rules are conflicting the
most which rules are the least accurate
so you can go and change those rules to
get better results typically if you have
good rules what you expect is that you
get like a good amount of positive
results a good amount of negative
results and the zero ones are ones that
the rules could not decipher this is
like when a one intermediate output of a
rule that I put in here just to show you
that when you start the process you
won't get something this nice and you
have to basically go through your data
to create
a good amount of positive and negative
rules and here you see the negative is
very small because in this particular
data set I could not think of what
characteristics would generate the
negative data and after this process
once you have the rules once you have
the candidates all you do is you feed it
to the learner and the learner tells you
oh there's one more step by that I
missed and sorry about that which is
before the rules and I'll kind of go
into it when I I have a small demo at
the end before the rules is also a step
where you go into a UI and you annotate
around hundred labels and the rules kind
of used those hundred labels and the
learner uses those hundred labels to get
to the answer and this is like an
example of the results derived from the
FDA drug labels so we're looking at
lithium carbonate and these were several
of the candidates bipolar disorder
individual maintainence manic episode
and snorkel kind of labeled bipolar
disorder and manic episode as a ones
that lithium carbonate creeps so this
was one of the goals of the things that
we were trying to do so most of the time
if you for like if you don't spend a lot
of time with the data and if you like
spend let's say two three weeks with
snorkel and the data it's possible to go
somewhere between 65 to 70 percent
accuracy and bear in mind you don't have
any training data than just a hundred
that you labeled which is pretty good
now going to 80% from 70% to 80%
requires quite a bit of effort in terms
of iterating through the process of
rules to the process of getting better
rules or candidates and these rules I
mean the way they are modeled inside the
code is that they're modeled as a soft
max with a bunch of parameters and then
people do keep sampling on top of it to
act to evaluate those parameters so it's
not it's not magic it's some regular
math another thing that I am very fond
of is just having like a docker
container for most of the things that
I do primarily because I kind of move I
sometimes work on my machine I work on
our local cluster and on flying scudd
stirs so moving things around is really
easy for with the docker container and I
don't have to worry too much about it
and my setting pretty much gets done in
this one file where I have a requirement
start txt where I have the Python stuff
and then I have the other Ubuntu stuff
in the docker file and that's pretty
much it
now if I compare like a typical machine
learning pipeline with snorkle there are
a bunch of things I do like typically in
machine learning I use I could learn to
do all of the stuff so I'll have like
details of you know using the pipeline
stitching things together I talked about
you know how do i balance the training
set i talked about what vectors and
today my talk actually finished much
much quicker it almost finished much
quicker than it normally does simply
because snorkel takes care of all of
this and the only thing that it asks you
for is domain knowledge it asks you for
very good domain knowledge you have to
do some hyper parameter tuning and yeah
that's pretty much it of course the
codes right now are in research slash
development modes so the codes break a
lot but apart from that you don't need
to be like you don't need to worry about
feature generating features you don't
need to worry a lot about what kind of
what kind of machine learning technique
do you want to use you could if you
wanted to but you actually don't have to
the next thing yeah and finally I have
like the pros and cons of snark oh and
yeah and the main I mean the pros are
pretty pretty good and the main reason
why we use it despite the fact that it
is in development mode and it is really
hard to use a code that's breaking all
the time and then deliver the results to
the client is that we pretty much never
get training data and we also spend like
at most two to three months on a project
so that's a very small amount of time to
get an annotate data and do something
very good so even when we get a 70%
accuracy in the first few weeks that's a
huge bump for us a lot of times people
will see these results and get very
impressed and will work for them longer
this kind of idea can be used in a range
of like problems bank loans it's
something I spoke about before market
research reports is another project that
I worked on on similar ideas and in that
project the there were MBAs hired MBAs
with 8 years of experience hired to just
read through a lot of documents
proprietary and then go to Google and
search for some more and create reports
so in that case they didn't want to stop
reading but we just use this extraction
technique to point them to the right
paragraphs or to the right documents
that they were looking for so their
reading went down from three weeks to
one week so that was something that that
I really enjoyed working on and finally
if you want the code you can go to a
hazy research snorkel the best way to
work with this right now is to
collaborate with Professor Chris Ray's
team simply because the code is kind of
changing very fast and yeah and there is
not much documentation on top of it so
the only way I know how to do things is
either read through the code or ask me
ask people in the group what's going on
and this is the paper that kind of talks
about what's going on behind the scenes
with the rules and what kind of
probabilistic graphical models are using
and what statistical inference you're
doing to get here now that I have some
more time and you can also contact me if
you want to know more on how to kind of
use research and university code in a
very demanding setting now that I have a
little bit more time I'm going to have a
very very small demo I'm not going to
run this because I'm not sure this is on
the cluster and I'm not sure if I'm
connected it also takes a little bit of
time to run
but the thing that I want to show is for
this particular problem I kind of wrote
a candidate extractor and to make the
data really small I kind of only look
for infections chronic and depression
careful words and then I fed it to the
the sentence viewer and it kind of you
oh sorry
how do i okay
yeah so the first thing that I have is
I've loaded parse data which is
basically the output of Stanford NLP
parser and then I have written Canada
extractor which is basically a
combination of nouns and some of the
words that I wanted to look at again
this is like too specific for it so for
the real problem I would write something
way more general but this kind of brings
down the data set to a huge extent mmm
and then you have the choice of putting
it in a viewer and the nice thing about
the viewer here is that this is like
this process also very iterative so you
might or might not like what you're
seeing so you go back and you change the
change the candidate extractor to see if
you get if you're getting the type of
candidates that you really want and this
is the big kind of data that comes up
and yeah in this case like we see a lot
of good data here just because of the
just because I have made it pretty I've
made it through pretty narrow the other
thing that I wanted to show was the UI
for and by the way most of the things
that I'm showing in the demo like I
didn't really make a formal demo because
things are changing sorry things are
changing so much that like whatever I
show today will have completely changed
next week not necessarily conceptually
but just like the UI or and not even
necessarily the UI's because it takes
time to write the US but the way the
commands are called or
yeah so this is like the UI for
annotating data so you can go in and
this I already annotated as as a disease
and this is respiratory tract infection
but since it only has tract infection
I'm going to label it as a negative one
and discard the whole one so I'm going
to label it as a positive one this talks
about urinary tract infections which is
kind of correct so this is like the UI
interface for the human annotation in
between and for most of the client
projects what we do is we send this my
tagger screen to the clients SME and
explain how to use it and they'll
typically tag it and send it back to us
so that's it from me yeah I'm open to
questions yes after you've written all
the rules and you said there was like
some hyper parameter tuning so is that
does that involve you manually changing
the rules no so when I send
hyperparameters to nning it's kind of
the same kind of thing that you do for a
psychic learn in the sense that you have
a range of regularization or you like
almost similar parameter is because the
similar classifiers have been used in
the background so I didn't go much into
it because yeah it's that's what I meant
okay then do you ever change the rules
yeah do you think there's a way to
automatically do that like include those
as parameters of the model so we are
kind of working on that because so we're
kind of working on the general concept
so you don't have to even write the rule
code you kind of encode the rules in
some way and the code takes those rules
and converts it into whatever the code
needs it like you encode your general
knowledge and then that gets encoded
right now it's not in the form that you
can change the rules as hyper
meters the idea is that you do like one
iteration and you kind of see which are
your worst rules from just a rule
analysis you also see like which what
like do you need a fresh set of
candidates because your accuracy is
lower in some kind of candidates and
then you go back and iterate so maybe at
the first go label a hundred of the
hundred annotations write a bunch of
rules and my expectation is your results
are not going to be better than 50% just
because if you don't know much about the
domain my expectation is that it's not
going to be very good then you examine
the rules but you probably even go back
to the candidates and look at the words
around the candidates which kind of get
encoded in the rules and you make the
rules better it's also possible that you
need to make your candidate extract or
better so you kind of work on that part
as well and through iteration like throw
a few iteration it's very easy to go to
like 65 to 70 percent even without being
a domain expert but just by looking
through looking at the data and going
through this process okay thanks
Thanks wondering if this is looks like
your examples were for candidate
extraction wondering if this could be
applied for overall text labeling like
spam classification something like that
it could be I thought about it this
specific paper does not deal with it at
all
but when I looked at this paper that's
the first thing I thought about that
this is not this should not be
restricted to text if you have a bunch
of rules then you should be able to get
like you should be able to somehow get
out of training data the concept of
active learning is around this space and
so wonder one of the things that the
code does is it takes the rules but it
also puts the candidates on a Patra
graph and it doesn't keep sampling on
top of it so I'm not sure if that part
is translatable to just about any data
just because candidates and text have
some property but it should you should
be able to take a bunch of rules and
model something for your data and then
if you look at this plot yeah so if
you're able to if you're able to get
like the plus ones and the minus ones
with your rules a good amount and then
in the center go to your zeroes and
label a hundred of your zeros and then
you should be in a good position to go
to iterate over that and do away with
training data and a lot of the active
learning projects are actually doing
that yep Samantha
actually I have two questions cuz I
thought of another one just now so my
first question you said you were doing
limit ization in your initial
description but then it seemed like
maybe you aren't doing that so yes I am
doing that I don't do that myself I like
let the Stanford no.3 parser do it and I
only do that myself when the text is
either very just well I mainly work with
English but when the text is extremely
unstructured for the parser to handle or
the parser gives garbage out and that
happens with machine generated text or
text with a lot of port numbers and a
different like where numbers letters are
combined and it doesn't make sense it
also happens when people write other
languages a lot and like you're writing
a different language but you're still
using English characters then it's hard
for the parser to work on that go I was
specifically wondering because you were
mentioning clinical terms in my
experience stemming those doesn't work
the way it should
I don't do stemming I do limit ization
and what happens is for the there are a
lot of disease terms and drugs that
don't have route and then you just get
that term itself and I when I do the
analysis I have both the words and the
lemmas and depending and they kind of
get useful in the rules part where I say
I expect this for I expect this kind of
word in the words and then I expect this
kind of thing in the lemmas so actually
that was my next question which is how
is there a rule of thumb for how many
rules you need for it to be useful there
is not a proper rule of thumb but 20
would be a good number to start with
having said that typically I barely get
10 when I do the first run it's just
because I don't know enough about the
data to write more than 10 rules
wondering since you do have labeled data
to begin with have you thought about
creating the rules learn the rules from
the labeled data so I don't have little
data to begin with that's the assumption
but yes that's something also that we
are actually working on let's say you
have some training data can you feed it
to a code and it just outputs the rules
to you and that's definitely possible
like one very very simple example would
be for instance for the medical space I
kind of worked like quite a long time in
the pharma space so I learned a lot of
jar I mean I learned quite a bit about
it so I have this list of stock words
that I know are not disease names but
are picked up very regularly so I could
take those top words and just write a
code that basically has four for the
number of stop words it has that many
rules said these should not be there and
that's a very very basic case like you
have to analyze the if you have more if
you have better training data you have
to analyze it's a little better to write
the rules but yeah I mean if you have
100 training that a data that's getting
tagged we are definitely thinking about
how to automate that information to
write the rules
in it
okay thank you thanks a lot good